dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear let's talk
about the behavior of cloth in
animations in Disney movies you often
see characters wandering around in
extremely realistically behaving apparel
it sounds like something that would be
extremely laborious to create by hand do
animators have to create all of this
movement by hand not a chance we use
computer programs to simulate the forces
that act on the fabric which starts
bending and stretching in a number of
different directions the more detailed
simulations we are looking for the more
computational time we have to invest and
the more we have to wait the
computations can take up to a minute for
every image but if we have lots of
movement and different fabrics in the
scene it can take even more is there a
solution for this
can we get really high quality
simulations in a reasonable amount of
time of course we can the name of the
game is adaptive simulation again we
have talked about adaptive fluid
simulations before adaptive means that
the technique tries to adapt to the
problem that we have at hand here in the
world of cloth simulations it means that
the algorithm tries to invest more
resources in computing regions that are
likely to have high fidelity details
such as wrinkles these regions are
marked with red to show that wrinkles
are likely to form here the blue and
yellow denotes regions where there is
not so much going on therefore we don't
have to do too many calculations there
these are the places where we can save a
lot of computational resources
this example illustrates the concept
extremely well take a look
while the fabric is at rest it's mostly
blue and yellow
but as forces are exerted on it wrinkles
appear and the algorithm recognizes that
these are the regions that we really
need to focus on with this adaptive
technique the simulation time for every
picture that we create is reduced
substantially
luckily some cloth simulation routines
are implemented in blender which is an
amazing free software package that is
definitely worth checking out
I've put some links in the description
box to get you started thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time